american horror story is never a show
that shies away from the potential for
controversy from its inception in 2011
the fx horror anthology has consistently
pushed the envelope and forced viewers
to confront some of their deepest fears
while coven is typically regarded as one
of the most beloved seasons of the show
it was still full of many moments of
horse fans to stop and consider what
they were watching the witchy third
season indulges in campiness alongside
the horror but also included many
genuinely uncomfortable moments that
made fans squirm in their seats for all
the wrong reasons there were plenty of
not safer work scenes that got the fans
especially because many of them veered
heavily into lurid and exploitative
imagery there were also several graphic
torture scenes where people lost body
parts in terrifying ways coven stood out
just as much for its occult themes as it
did for its gory scenes on the show's
subreddit one user asked fans to share
what scenes they found the scariest one
fan jokingly called the show american
trauma story after scrolling through all
of the frightening scenes however one
scene from coven came up multiple times
and stood out among the various answers
we actually wonder how reddit managed to
narrow it down to just one that went too
far the mere idea of madame delphine
played by kathy bates systematically
removing the toes of a gardener who had
the audacity to come looking for a
bandage makes our hair stand on end
there's also the self-imposed punishment
of cordelia where she decides that she
can only gain the sight by destroying
her own eyes with a set of garden shears
if nothing else it's a great excuse to
never do any work outside in the near
future my blindness
gave me real vision but it's of no use
to me now not when there are witch
hunters right outside our door
while we're on the subject of eyes we
can't forget about the big murder moment
for myrtle the next time you get a
craving for fresh fruit try not to think
about the time she scooped out the eyes
from the sockets of quentin and pimby
it's bad enough that she extracts these
from her two victims while they're still
alive but she took him a step further
thanks to one of her concoctions cecily
and quentin are completely immobilized
during this impromptu surgery they can
still feel every agonizing moment while
myrtle revels and her revenge we could
spend hours dissecting the brutal
moments throughout ahs coven that make
us want to reconsider ever attending a
dinner party involving cocktails with
garnishes but there is only one that
will haunt us until the end of our days
in keeping with many fans criticisms of
coven that have popped up in
retrospectives of american horror story
several redditors pointed to the opening
scene of the season premiere as being
particularly difficult to watch although
we would say that's putting it mildly
the episode opens with real life serial
killer madame delphine lalorie hosting a
party in new orleans where she is
punishing one of her daughters for
trying to seduce a black horseman in
truly sadistic fashion he is the one who
bears the brunt of the punishment what
follows is one of the most horrifying
sequences in the history of ahs
transcending the horror genre and
hitting even closer to home than today's
cultural climate the sadistic socialite
brings demand bastion to the addict
where it's revealed that she keeps many
others in a makeshift torture chamber
delphine cruelly mocks her abused
captives calling them her pets as they
watch in horror while bastian's head is
covered by a hollowed-out bull's head he
whimpers while she says he's to become a
beast since he acted like one citing her
inspiration as the mythological greek
minotaur the head is then bonded to his
body completing the transformation fans
agreed that the brutal grotesque scene
went too far with users claiming they
almost gave up on the rest of the season
due to this opener despite staying on
the air for a decade it makes us wonder
how many potential american horror story
fans have checked out thanks to the
plethora of shocking moments throughout
the show's history
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one